we're going to talk about the natural
response of an lc circuit inductor
capacitor circuit
and this is an interesting one this is a
circuit that has two energy storage
elements in the past videos we've done
one energy storage element either a c
or an l and this time we're going to put
them together and see what they do
as a pair
and there's no resistor in this circuit
so
this is interesting because we have two
energy storage elements
elements
well what does that mean that means for
a capacitor
there's some charge
stored on the on the capacitor and that
typically means that there's an excess
of charge on one of the plates
so in this case there's an excess of
positive charge on the top plate or you
could say the same way there's a a lack
of
negative charge there's some negative
charge missing from the top plate and
that's there's some extra negative
charge on the bottom plate
so that's what we mean by a capacitor
storing charge
so how does an inductor store energy
well that stores its energy in a
magnetic field it's out in the space
around
around the inductor
so when we have a current flowing an
inductor
its energy is stored in a magnetic field
like that
so that's what we mean by two energy
storage elements
now one thing we know about the q
in a capacitor is q equals
cv
so if there's some q here
that means there's some voltage here
so this is the voltage we're going to
track in this circuit that's the voltage
between these two nodes here
and
because there's an inductor
one of the interesting things is the
current in the inductor so i'm going to
draw the current arrow this way
and one thing i want to point out is if
i define the inductor current going down
through the inductor that same current
is going up
through the capacitor
so our challenge when we want to know
what the natural response of this is is
we put in some energy and in this case
we'll put in some q on the capacitor and
we'll let i start at zero
and then we step back and we watch what
this circuit does
and what that means is we figure out
what the voltage is as a function of
time and the current is a function of
time and both of those things together
is the natural response of an lc circuit
so in this video what i want to do is
predict the shape
we're going to predict v and i
we're just going to do this intuitively
and then in the next sequence of videos
we'll work it out exactly with a
mathematical precision what this natural
response looks like and then we'll look
to see if the mathematics matches our
intuition
a good way to uh to make this prediction
what we're going to do is we're going to
follow and track what happens to this
charge here as it
as this circuit relaxes in its natural
response
so first thing let's just write some
equations the element equations for the
l and the c
and we know for an inductor
v
equals l times d i
dt
so voltage is proportional to the value
of the inductor times the slope of the
current or the rate of change of the
current
for a capacitor we know that i
equals c times the slope of the voltage
dv
dt
and one thing we know is that both of
these equations
are true all the time
so that's going to help us out and the
way we look at this intuitively is we're
going to track the charge and we're
going to look at what happens in this
circuit moment to moment as that charge
moves around
so what i'm going to do just to get us
set up just to get a set up here i'm
going to take out a little chunk of this
circuit here
and then put in a switch
like that
so here's
here's a switch and that switch is going
to close
at time equals zero
so before the switch closes we're going
to put some charge on this capacitor
there's going to be a voltage on the
capacitor
the capacitor will have a voltage of v
naught so that means that v
of
of time less than zero
equals v naught we'll just call it v
naught
and what else do we know well the switch
is open so that means that the current
through this
loop the current in our circuit is zero
so i
we can write i
of t less than zero
equals zero so there's two things we
know about the circuit
so now we're ready to close the switch
and we're going to take a break right
now and i'll see you in the next video